he's coming over he's very excited about
the visit and you know it's a great
honor to be over here and I think it's
you know once again
I mean his idea is to look back at 75
years ago in 1944 and d-day and also to
look forward and what d-day met and all
the heroism and all the dedicated people
in the war and try to bring that forward
and make sure that the relationship we
have between our two countries remains
the strongest of any two countries in
the world I think wait perhaps a little
surprise that he's coming back again so
soon less than a year since he was here
previously what more can be achieved on
a political level this time do you think
well I think the more time you spend in
a country and talking to people and that
the better you know and especially since
our two countries are so closely aligned
that you know frequent trips are good
and it's good to communicate with each
other and see each other face to face
and get a feel for you know a continued
feel for what's happening in Britain the
Stila question mark at this stage isn't
that over his address to parliament and
labour saying it's a colossal waste of
money
this trip what's your reaction to that
well my reaction is I don't know where
that came from
but no it's never a colossal waste of
anything to talk to your allies and talk
to your friends and talk to your big
biggest business partner one of the
biggest business partners the US has if
that's considered a waste and I've never
heard that before and what about the
speaker speaker Burke oh I'm sure you're
aware of his work he and not least with
brexit over the last few months
he previously wouldn't allow the leader
of the free world to address MPs what
would you like to say to him this time
I'm bastard tries to convince him that
it is a good thing to do I would say
that the schedule and what the president
wants to do I'll leave to the president
and his staff in terms of what actually
they want to accomplish on those trips
specifically and
the scheduling of that what do you think
it's important that he does address MPs
I think that that's how I'll leave that
to the president I think he's going to
work on broader issues in terms of there
was a relationship the Security and
Prosperity of our two nations he's gonna
be here he's devoting three three days
to being over here that's a major major
time commitment and but I think it's an
important one how concerned would he be
about demonstrations I'm sure you're
aware that there are public
demonstrations that have been planned we
saw them last time but of course he
didn't really spend much time in London
city centre last time today he was in
Windsor with the Queen he was out with
MPs as well out in in the Shires he
wasn't really in London very much we
didn't see any demonstrations if he's in
London
he'll be driving up the mile with her
majesty I'm guessing because it's a
state visit so it will be more aware of
demonstrations this time well I think
the president is is not going to be
intimidated or influenced by
demonstrations if there are any you know
I think this is a great you know my own
view is the relationship between our two
countries is very important for both of
us so having the president here is very
beneficial for the British people and
everything that our relationship
represents which is all positives and
rest assured that this country is very
important to the president his mother
was born here and so he wants to keep
that you as allies and keep that
relationship alive well and prospering
and growing and he's quite keen on
meeting the Queen again I am guessing
yes yes they had afternoon tea together
last time when what is it they might
have supper together this time I think
that may be on the air that may be on
the schedule okay looking forward to
it's good to talk to you mr. ambassador
thank you very much thank you okay thank
you thank you thank you very much